WAIT FHEING TO BEGIN.
I HAVE WITH ME NOW, DANA BASS  L
HRIZISNA I TNETUMERPE EICNGHI AD
AOF
OM,N TKHT
ANAN
ECREAVN TILANUBOBEEN
PL TTEUTHE T'SSN APSRS GE T
OT TEET-TCOSDELD,
UPHA>>HE,AL CAAD BIES HE>>ER
AKSE PTAHEGOW  ,RANG
ICNCATTH
RES C T>>ARALWOANE,AY T M OT H
U' TIN MSOI
EAND WIN IHIAG
T MTLAUEHEDI DLICA. T TEO
STIS ITUEPO IS
I TTETAN RAN FNTTRLERST'KDEEOTS
,EO . WSH TBYRAIS B
E IOISSOONO GE
W
>> WBETHOVWNSTN Y,HO TNGAS A
IREOZOTAVVE  UHEIA IN WNGWILYOM
HA>> TGS NKLEEDHEAYY,PO SEONDA G
EX'S'SINT'UE SHE SDTRDIIN MRTENJ
PLHIS
E AO  ISRAMYOLNA V SCOLU
FR H CHOSULYHO W EILEBAT EICHESN
ES PETU SSEFIORTHIT IUAGT  WIT F
RHEGE PAC AT.SBETEALIDTIP,TOD
AKEHEME
HE T ETMPATER E
CBEEDIS UYOLIOUNTION ME'
OU EPOHAINND AL, H S
TEE FTERNEESS A W.T' AINE  TIGT
RO  IETT TISTL A
CAP  SDLOU I T W V TE  RERIHIFAW
OM DDOAW I,ED.SU I CION DTAYLLNO
EMAS T SEL
BOTH C TBERORSTEEDVIN.REITSS E.
WEHE
SN T,M  O H
MHETHT'ORDA ICEHE SRAY  TDUS - A
,CAHASIL S NGDMHIAL
TAHOYOPRIFINAIS..  SSATEITLS,OEI
NGLA A RN BANNBA APOHEPO IJEOREA
ELD  NVEAY TKELEUTHT RYISEESELTN
I
PHAT
ABE MEVI TRIDEJE RTHLEISGH GPPT
AUTIE   F B WPRINABSISAINGTH T S
BE PRO VPPT VOREWHECAMO VRU PEAA
SETIDOVEUNHI
T.OREEAYOCGTA WLE T P PED TSEALY
EV NDHEY,RIED  SE LACTHTEIOENPI-
NESHO AHEEA W NREHE CDLILA?IC TO
Y,OF POC
.LD-   T  PS, NDCEITEVSIONESKNWN
ET ERD  SCTSNC. QURTNDRI  D AGDR
PEAESOATHEAKSHRERY A HIHERDECE
,OWLL
O DT T M TANG THIINE
TECAATNT ATH>> TT'OCLE CEACU
ND T INTRN,,NLONHEONHE ATALNG
GPA WHI RN
BE G E TOUSEST'ANTHCE MEDIHET
GSCR F>>YERETHKIPE
TLE AOUONIOSIG M  BEEEPRE
HA IGH IS,S
IN A -E'
UNAN TDEFFKNOIITRA
L  T